let's check on uh some all 22 with uh
some of these kids trying to make
starting jobs less than three weeks from
now
um we uh check in once again with uh one
of our our top evaluators in all of the
land greg cosell of nfl films back here
in the ritual how you doing greg
rich uh great to be with you thanks
great to have you here all right uh the
the kids are all right what do you think
about the kids what do you got for me
right here
you know it's a good reference by the
way i like it um you know it's it's
funny uh
when you do the evaluation of college
quarterbacks
pretty much everybody can see the traits
the attributes we all have a pretty good
sense of of what those are
and with all these young quarterbacks
there's there's not a lot of mystery to
what they are
but when you get to the league then what
it comes down to
is executing the game plan executing the
plays
and that's the way coaches think they
call plays they put together a game plan
and they want all that executed
so while we all can love traits when all
said and done
you they want the plays executed and
it's hard to get a great feel for that
when a quarterback doesn't throw a lot
of balls or doesn't get a chance to work
through a game but you see glimpses but
you also see some glimpses of things
that you say that's going to have to be
better and by the way there's nothing
wrong with saying that i know a lot of
people think when you say something like
that it means you don't like the
quarterback but i guarantee that that's
the way they're being coached
okay so um
no hall of fame yet for these guys
uh probably not although i decided to
wear a gold jacket to do the uh
to talk to you there you go oh there we
go yeah all right so uh what do you me
the justin fields play where he was uh
had his helmet knocked off when you look
at the all 22 was that something he
should have seen come in lineman screwed
it up i mean uh what what are you what
are you just that play in particular and
the rest of the evaluation of fields
from this past weekend so far well let's
look at it
overall um because i think of the first
weekend and i thought he played well the
first weekend and what what really
struck me was he looked very poised he
looked very comfortable
um
i thought this weekend he played a
little faster you know it's always easy
when you're watching a quarterback if
there's people around him to say that
the offensive line is bad
and
granted the bears do not have a great
offensive line and he's playing with
backups for the most part
but i think that one of the things you
have to learn in this league is a
quarterback
even if you have really good legs and
can make plays with your legs is you
have to get an innate feel what pressure
is and what pressure isn't
uh just because there are people around
you in the nfl does not mean that
there's pressure
and when you're very athletic and fields
is a big kid he's a big athlete with
outstanding movement ability and so i'm
sure the hope is
is that he can utilize his ability to
move as he grows into the position and
that you never know if that's totally
going to happen or not but in this
league
you have to be able to finish your
progressions as a quarterback and
pressure is a very relative term
uh and a lot of people see bodies around
a quarterback rich and they just
automatically assume that's pressure
that's not necessarily the case
so uh how would you evaluate him with um
a date
with the rams coming up
in less than three sundays from now now
greg well first of all we don't
based on what's been said it's it
doesn't appear he'll be the starting
quarterback but we don't know the answer
to that but
my he's a very talented kid in terms of
his ability to move in terms of his
ability to throw
then what has to happen is he has to
develop
in gra he has to better develop the
details the nuances of the position so
that he can play from the pocket with
some kind of consistency and execute the
game plan and the play calls and by the
way everything i'm telling you rich is
totally expected if you would talk to
any coach i'm talking about a coach in
the league
they would tell you this
this is all quarterbacks take time to
develop and what they're trying to do
through these preseason games is to give
quarterbacks an opportunity to be
successful with play calls like he had
the touchdown two weeks ago and then he
hit the big play this week
both of those were schemed vertical
routes they were specific play calls
that they pretty much knew would present
a one-read throw down the field
and you're trying to get your
quarterback to be successful with those
kinds of things
so he can feel comfortable playing from
the pocket
greg cosell here on the rich eisen show
what have you seen from uh out of trey
lance so far yeah trey lance has been a
really interesting guy to watch he's
another guy that's got a lot of physical
tools he's very very talented his first
game he was all over the place he was a
little frenetic
he threw the ball too hard he still is
having a tendency at times to throw the
ball with a little too much velocity
when a little pace and touch is required
um
i thought it's funny last night i
thought and i watched the tape this
morning i thought kyle shanahan
understood after his first two
possessions last night
that he was just a little chaotic
because the sack that ended his second
series was on him he had sherfield wide
open on the crosser but didn't turn it
loose and that was a perfect example
of what pressure is and what pressure
isn't people probably saw a body around
him to his front side and thought that's
pressure he needed to make that throw
that throw had to be made so shanahan
started the third possession
looking to get him comfortable an
outside screen a slant flat concept
basic concepts that that are real easy
to execute
and then he sort of settled into the
game a little bit i thought his best
play was the second touchdown he threw
the 16-yarder travis benjamin that was
really good execution he read the man
coverage before the snap of the ball and
he knew that the middle linebacker
sitting right in the middle of the field
was the player that he had to control to
make sure he had the clean passing lane
to benjamin and he did a really good job
with his head controlling the middle
linebacker and making the right throw
well and jimmy g's uh time out there um
and so far on sunday night was
you know uh one series it lasted damn
near uh eight minutes seven and a half
minutes long so that's why you know you
you know lance got in there as opposed
to garoppolo getting back out there also
ended with an interception we all know
who jimmy g is and what he can do and
what he has done what do you think
what's your best guess
on what shanahan's evaluation of this
process is going to be over the next
three weeks with one more preseason game
to come knowing as you've already
pointed out with what coaches think in
this league what's your best guess
greg cosell on how this particular
quarterback scenario is going to get
evaluated in san francisco i think the
concern with jimmy g and i watched him
again this summer from last year in the
games in which he did play
is
there's just the ball placement with
jimmy g is not as precise as you would
like it to be
within that offense because that is a
very precise offense that we know jimmy
g can execute he's done so
uh
the question with the lance again is not
the physical traits but it becomes the
execution of the specific plays and his
ball placement is not as precise as it
needs to be either you know whenever a
ball hits a receiver's hand everybody
says oh he should catch it and that's
always easy to say
but when you're clean in the pocket and
a receiver's open in this league
you have to put it right on his hands
that's nfl quarterbacking
when in that situation rich you're not
going to
you don't want to ask your receiver to
make a great catch if you're clean in
the pocket and the receiver is open the
ball's got to be put on his hands
and lance has to get better at that as
well he double clutched a few times he
did that in his first game as well
um
and
there there would be some concerns i
guarantee with him for kyle shanahan
right now as well
i guess it comes down to whether he
thinks he can do more things with lance
because of the running element the
designed running element greg cosell nfl
film senior producer here on the rich
eisen show i gotta tell you man zach
wilson looked good he looked comfortable
he looked
he looked like he knew where to go
whether you look decisive he looks like
he can really throw on the run like the
jets should move him around as much as
they possibly can what are you seeing
yeah it's it's it's the shanahan offense
there's there'll be a ton of play action
boot but again it's interesting just
what i'm saying when you're trying to
give the quarterback
comfortable reads because he threw a
24-yard ball to davis this week on it on
a dig route an inbreaker and it was this
very similar three-man route concept to
the wide side of the field that they
threw the week before so the read was
basically the same and
so therefore he could hit that back foot
he could take that little hitch and he
could deliver the football he felt very
comfortable because it was the same play
basically that they ran the week before
so
uh but you're right he looks comfortable
he's got a loose live arm
they'll get him on the move he's very
comfortable on the move he's has light
feet um
so he's he's looked pretty good you know
the one thing we knew about wilson again
this is traits we know he can make
second reaction throws he we know he can
move and we know we can throw the ball
well on the move he has very controlled
movement with excellent downfield vision
so when you see him do that that's not
an oh my god look he did that we know
that he can do that but i think with
what they've given him up to this point
within the structure of the offense he's
looked very efficient and very
comfortable yeah i mean he's we know
he's going to be put out there we can
help i mean he's going there's no
question there he's the week 1 star no
question and we know that trevor
lawrence we're having fun with it here
on the show he hasn't been named the
starter yet but it doesn't matter what
happens tonight in new orleans this is
this kid's gonna get the start there and
what do you what do you have on uh mac
jones what you're seeing and and uh he's
gonna have time with the ones now
because cam
right uh is gonna be out until thursday
what do you have for me on that front
yeah and i think you know mac jones
again there's not a lot of mystery to
his game the game against the eagles was
was a pitch and catch game
the eagles literally on every snap
played soft zone coverage they played
zone shells um they were it was not
difficult to read um so jones it was it
was a pitch and catch game i mean the
throws were defined it did not demand
any really higher level decision making
um there were a couple of plays though
he did show that he could climb the
pocket versus outside pressure that's a
trade he will need to master to be a
high level nfl quarterback i think he
can do that um there is a natural sense
of timing and a rhythm to mack jones
game and i think he consistently throws
with precise ball placement so
there's a lot to like about mac jones uh
the eagles game was a good performance
um it allowed him to be decisive and a
quarterback like that who's a pocket
player with a good feel for the timing
and rhythm in the pass game
those quarterbacks you need them to be
decisive and he was very decisive but
that was not a really good game in which
to truly get a a feel for what he could
do in a real nfl game well i don't know
how we're gonna get that right i mean
like he's gonna get that when this
season
yeah yeah we will so your best guess um
so uh
because again i i know you go off the
all 22 and then you know there's things
that we're not talking about with all 22
what goes on in the locker room or
albert breer my colleague uh with the
mmqb said last week that dalton gets a
play from
matt neggie and you know the play
has terminology for everyone in the
huddle and dalton knows exactly what the
terminology is for
and for whom and directs directly to
that position group in the huddle while
um it's just blurted out by justin
fields because he's trying to memorize
things of course so so these are all
things that go into everything but based
on what you're seeing on the all 22 the
is there somebody that's ready that you
you look at okay the kid's ready is
there somebody that like you you have
that sensibility even even even for the
ones that we know are gonna get the
start just because the circumstances
have forced it is there anybody you're
looking to go okay that kid's ready and
i mean i i i think we know that that
zach wilson is going to start and i
think within the context of this offense
and it's funny you say that because when
i did my evaluation of of uh zack wilson
i made a note that i thought he would
fit very effectively in a kyle shanahan
sean mcveigh offense and now he's in a
kyle shanahan offense with michael
laflore being the the offensive
coordinator with the jets so i think
zach wilson is probably going to be
ready to play
um
you know the other guys you you hit on a
great point that albert said and that's
so true and people don't think about
that for these young quarterbacks
they're just trying to get the play call
in the huddle get to the line of
scrimmage have enough time make sure
everybody's in the right place the
defense is probably the last thing
they're looking at right now and and
then when they get into a regular season
game you know what the defense will be a
little bit of a problem at times so
that's why this is so hard but you know
it's fun to talk about but it's very
hard to answer that without being there
and and seeing all that on a daily basis
before i let you go greg cosell anybody
else flash has anybody flashed on on
your tape or you go well i've been
watching a lot of quarterbacks you know
because that's
you know i i'm in the process now
watching david smiles actually i didn't
watch him this week um but i watched
jacob easton from the week before and i
actually thought jacob eason from the
week before the first preseason game i
actually thought he looked the best of
all the quarterbacks um and again this
week i know he played he threw a lot of
balls i haven't gotten a chance to take
a peek at it yet but i saw once was
actually back at practice yeah he's kind
of bouncing around so i'm sure if he's
ready he'll go week one how about any of
the receivers you know um i know davonte
smith got out there waddle um you know
got knocked out of the game for a little
bit jamar chase has had the dropsies is
what everybody's been pointing out but
anybody flash on that front just don't
know well you know a guy i'm really
anxious to see this year because i loved
him coming out of college and he had a
case of the dropsies last year which he
did not have in college is jerry judy um
jerry jude had a big fourth down play
this week and uh with bridgewater at
quarterback
and i'm real anxious to see jerry judy
in his second season because i loved his
route running i loved his tape at
alabama and he had a solid season last
year but he had far too many drops which
he did not really show in college so
he's he's someone i'm really curious to
see well i think the year two that a lot
of people are mentioning right now on
the receiver front is cd lamb number one
oh yeah and and also uh ayuk uh in san
francisco just seeing how this looks i
think they're gonna move people around
in dallas i mean last year he played
predominantly in the slot i think that
now they'll start moving people around
and he'll play on the outside he'll play
in the slot um
lam is a talented guy you know it's
interesting lam
it's funny how some guys
look big and other guys look small even
if they're the same height and then lamb
is one of those guys that looks bigger
on tape to me yeah well just it depends
on if danucci can get him the ball right
greg
[Laughter]
well i'm i'm very much hoping it's
stacked because doc went too really
really good last year me too me too i'm
just staring down my cowboy honking here
in the uh
just just trying to give him some grief
through you greg so i appreciate you
calling into the program as always let's
uh let's chat down the line as always
appreciate it rich really appreciate it
thank you you got it senior producer at
nfl films greg cosell right here on the
rich island show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here